is because the sort of woman that would
go on your show is a very specific do
you think so because I I interview women
on the street all the time like I it's
random half the girls come that come on
my show don't even know what show
they're coming on yeah so it's like it's
very random but that's I think that's
the point I'm making the fact that they
would say yes to it because I know a lot
of women who just wouldn't say yes to it
just because they don't want to be out
there they don't want to be on social
with her yeah and so they just wouldn't
okay they wouldn't say yes but you would
agree that the general Trend that women
are [__] now than they were oh no of
course I definitely agree 50 if you had
two partners you were over I think the
average man prays for two
I definitely agree that obviously you
know yeah people are becoming more
promiscuous yeah you know but then don't
you think that do you think that the
current Red Bull message is Hope in the
um I think it's waking like okay so you
have the top 20 of guys let's say 20.
some red pill guys would argue five
percent of guys someone argue 10 let's
say 20 are screwing all the girls and
the next like 30 of the guys that get
them after they get the leftovers that's
why they say leftover women and so a lot
of guys are marrying a girl thinking
that they're that girl's first choice
because they're marrying her but really
like she wants the guys that she slept
with in her 20s
and so I think it's important for guys
to understand
that if you if you date a more
promiscuous woman it's more likely that
she's going to leave because she only
wanted you for the kids and the
resources but see this is this is a
point in where I have somewhat a bit of
contention because we always say that if
a man marries a woman he's being
promiscuous then she's more like to
leave but then we've also the same stats
will also show that if a man has a
higher body count he's also more likely
to be uh less sexually satisfied and so
that could lead to him stepping on
America not necessarily because at like
three to four
um he actually has a higher of marriage
satisfaction at seven to eight Partners
than he does it three to four
so but you're right the the I mean I
always say like if you can get two
virgins that's the ideal that's the
happiest marriage but
um it the the point is that promiscuity
affects women more than men and modern
society explain in more sense well so
the average
um women that sleep with five or more
Partners have less than a 30 percent
chance of a happy marriage after 10
years where a virgin has an 80 chance
you don't see that level of drop off
among men do you see that you're right I
don't just they don't most red pill
channels wouldn't disagree with that I
mean I don't necessarily prescribe like
the F you know 30 before like I don't
tell people to sleep around yeah I say
this is the information do what you want
with it and the point is if a guy sleeps
with four partners and a guy sleeps with
eight Partners so double that he's more
happy in his marriage at eight I don't
know why the thing is I will say yeah
that is part of what do you like your
channel
so much because you don't tend to just
necessarily push people towards their
lifestyle you most of just State the
facts and state and yeah but I will say
a lot I think a lot of the more of the
current mainstream Red Bull content does
push that lifestyle does encourage it
and does that's true you say that and
that tends to be a place where I have a
problem with them because you know
they're saying they want to help men
right which I don't this I don't doubt
that that's where they that's what they
want to do however they're not actually
telling them in Lifestyles that would
actually most likely make them
um be happier in in a relationship why
why do they tell them that
I don't know
you tell me does marriage benefit the
average man today
it depends on what you mean exactly
is it beneficial for the average man to
get married
does the does the benefit outweigh the
risk
again it depends what you mean because
stats will show you that you know a man
who's married
um actually
[Music]
is less is less likely to be depressed
it's less likely to feel isolated is
more likely to what's it called to
recover from certain diseases than when
when it was more likely to have a better
health care when you know so I think
there are certain benefits that come
with getting married correct correct but
but your key key phrases is is married
yeah 50 divorce rate yeah so you have a
50 50 shot and if she leaves she tend to
take half your stuff and your kids that
makes it especially especially in the
U.S where a lot of these red pill
channels are based like
um so if you're there's a guy in
California whose wife left him took the
kid with her and went to Japan yeah and
you said did you see that video yeah
it's messed up like that's the level of
risk that men are facing and so it's
like if if if we're making men have this
level of responsibility like why would
you get married I wouldn't if I lived in
California if I was a dude and she could
take a quarter per kid 25 of my
after-tax income
that and if you lose your job and you
can't pay it you go to jail oh no see I
understand the argument I understand
that argument yeah right but then the
whole point of the reticle movement is
to push men to do better and to increase
a lot of things they say is to increase
your your income right yeah so it turns
out that marriages especially in the US
um once you get to a 250k threshold and
above divorces go down to plummet to 20.
still one out of four chance you can
take yeah like like I'm just saying
that's that's that's crazy like and the
point is if Men start walking away from
that maybe the laws will change but I
don't understand why the government
needs to be involved in marriage for me
the way I see is I think if you want to
get married someone you don't
necessarily have to you know there are
some tax benefits that people get from
you know from being actually married so
if you want those then do that however I
think to to say to push a narrative that
there's no benefit to a man being
married to a man to be married it's just
it's just wrong especially when we tell
when they tell people that a high value
man the only reason why they want to
marry a woman is to is for their legacy
and their children right well I don't
that's why I don't I don't tell people
not to get married but I understand why
they don't yeah and like I perfectly
understand why they tell my mom not to
get married when the laws are the way
they are that's that's like my view on
it I think people are free to choose of
course if that's the risk you want to
weigh but if I lived in Cal California
and that was oh God cart
I'm not laughing if you lived in
California like genuinely no no you make
you go let's say you get the 250 000 a
year and now you know there's a one in
four chance that you get divorced and
she's she can take your kids to another
country and take half your [__] yeah
I mean don't get me wrong I think
especially you want to understand why
those guys say you know you know what
I'm gonna just [__] a bunch of [__] I
think especially in America is yeah it's
especially bad over there it's not as
bad here is it I mean it's still 13 it's
still best come and they can still seize
your assets you know as I said it's
still bad but I think Americans it's
another level of just well okay yeah but
yeah I do think you know when you're
saying when you're saying they're higher
value men the only reason why they want
to get married so these modern women is
their kids right
not necessarily if you do roll out like
he's you know someone say The Godfather
of the red one he doesn't tell people
what to do he always says it's a
praxeology not an ideology he doesn't he
doesn't really give advice
she says these are these are the stats
to do with it what you want my problem
with role is that he is living a life
which he seems to be relatively happy in
but then he doesn't exactly tell people
um he doesn't exactly tell people what
he's done to be happy and or he doesn't
necessarily prescribe what he does talk
about what he did if you if you watch
more of it so I've watched his content
yeah and even he had a debate with as he
has like his rock star 20. yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he had this debate
with uh Russell and I think he I think I
don't know who that is it's just another
YouTuber
um and he basically said himself he
doesn't prescribe he just tells people
how it is right he he said that word for
what but the problem is is that in a
sense his people go to his wherever he
doesn't yeah people go to his books
because they want to learn um but what
he's trying to say is he is giving you
the tools do it do what you want with
the tools he doesn't give you the tools
because I would say he does so like I
think his his chart about women is
actually very accurate yeah so like you
know when girls around like 29 to 35 are
looking for more of a provider type I
think that's really good to know for men
that you know she's probably just
looking for you for your resources
that's good to know it's good to know
what an alpha Widow is
can you explain that for the people who
don't you've explained it's like it's
like an alpha widow's basically I'll
give you a story that goes with it and
Alpha what it was basically like a girl
that can't get over her ex like